If the shoe fits...
wear it!
I take apart
the new Cinderella--
--on this week's episode of Angry Nerd!
First, your comments.
Rodney Funderburrk writes,
“Can you make a video”
“about whether books or movies”
“are better for franchises like”
“Harry Potter, Lord of the Rings,
and Twilight?”
Rodney, books and movies
are two different mediums,
and each are good in there own ways!
Except for Twilight!
Twilight books and movies
are each BAD
in their own ways!
A live action version
of Disney's Cinderella
is coming out and...
it's giving me a powerful sense of deja vu.
I mean, there have been
THIRTEEN movie adaptations
of this story since 2000,
including Into the Woods
just a coupla months ago.
I don't see what sets this
new Kenneth Branagh adaptation apart...
Except more plot machinations
with the wicked stepmother--
YAWN!
Why is Disney turning yet another
animated classic into live action?
Is it because Maleficent earned over $750
million?
I guess they--
Yeah, I figured that was the reason why.
But I guess this new Cinderella
doesn't really have to reinvent the wheel,
because the 400 year-old storyline
is so durable and universally appealing.
People naturally respond
to the downtrodden protagonist
whose special qualities are finally recognized.
I can guarantee you that
they'll still be staging Cinderella
at outposts on Rigel 7
in the year 2395.
A story with that sort of
timeless appeal is potent stuff.
Seriously, has anybody in our lifetime
come up with a tale that we can
confidently predict
will still be in circulation
four centuries from now?
I would say…
George Lucas.
Imean, the man has a lot to answer for,
but in the pre-prequel era,
he really tapped into something primal.
“I... am your father!”
“Noooooooo!”
Remember in Reign of Fire
when the adults stage Star Wars
for the kids?
“I... am your father!”
“GASP!”
That was the best scene in that postapocalyptic
dud.
Who else's work will endure?
Stan Lee, maybe.
Future generations will still wish
they could be like the wallflower
who gains extraordinary super powers.
They'll probably also think that 20th century
people
were all so gullible and superstitious
that we really believed that radioactive arachnids
would actually have that effect!
I knew that that wasn't how science works,
people from the distant future!
Revive my cryofrozen head,
and I will explain our era to you.
Who else stands the test of time?
Walt Disney?
Yeah.
John Lasseter?
It's likely..
Dr. Seuss?
Natch.
Shigeru Miyamoto?
Of course!
J. K. Rowling?
No--
they'll find the educational system
elitist and brutalizing.
Michael Bay?
Are you kidding?!
His stuff seems archaic NOW!
So Disney's doing a live action Cinderella
this year,
and a live action Jungle Book
and Beauty and the Beast
are coming next year.
I mean what's next,
a live action Pirates of the Caribbean?!
What?
No, you're mistaken.
See, it’s very sophisticated animatronics,
just like the ride.
No, no, no,
because I read it in Variety, that’s--
not real people.
I hate it when you go “Well...”
And then you tell me that I’m wrong
when I know that I’m right!
They’re animatronic robots!
Nope, nope!
Well… we’ll agree to disagree.
I'm assuming that the future peoples
of the 24th century
won't have supershort attention spans
that prevent them from enjoying
ninety minute movies.
Maybe their touchstones will be
"Charlie Bit My Finger,"
or the cat who likes to jump into boxes.
What do you think
is the most durable story of our time?
Let me know in the comments,
subscribe to the Wired channel,
and click on my videos over there.
With the tiny animatronic versions of me.
What? No, no.
They're animatronic.
Look how stiff and jerky their movements are!
What a thing to say to me!
I bet YOU are animatronic!
Yeah, I thought so.
A real human being human
couldn't be that heartless.